the Elder Scrolls show us what was  and what yet who be  and they have revealed much to me spare  us your stories old man unless they can  sharpen Spears our war chief is dying  our enemies are massing for another  attack you must prepare for battle we  should go kill in we have this growl we  came for and this one smells blood in  the wind patience nog I have words yet  to speak here stories can do surprising  things beer maiden whether they are true  or not and this is one you should here  comes from the great war that nearly  ended the Empire it began when the high  Oh slaughter every Imperial place  calling themselves the new old Mary  Dominion  allies swept through the back  and capturing the imperial city itself  you  the Emperor fled North leaving Citadel  to the invaders this is the story of a  forgotten hero who changed the very  course of history  you